hi
let's see if i can get my slides up
there we go
so i want to talk a little bit about the
management and analysis of
pre-implantation genetic uh genetic
diagnosis data
and my name is dan taylor i'm an
assistant professor in
the department of obstetrics gynecology
and reproductive sciences at robert wood
johnson medical school
at rutgers university i'm also part of
the department of genetics
and i teach and serve in the graduate
school of molecular biosciences i also
wear another hat and then i am the
director of bioinformatics for the
reproductive medicine associates of new
jersey which includes rma
genetics which is a separate company and
i work for both
uh organizations
as a bioinformaticist
statistician and overall data jockey
so i want to talk a little bit about
topics in
managing data for clinical
clinical laboratories
so my topics are going to be data
standards and requirements for clinical
molecular diagnostic laboratories what
exists now
i also would like to discuss data and
pipelines for pgd as a molecular
diagnostic
i'd like to talk about next generation
sequencing pgd and human genetics in
future uh pre-implantation genetic
diagnosis
trends
um and each of these um the last topic
will be a little bit more speculative
and a little bit more about human
genetics and the first few topics we'll
talk about how data is handled in
clinical laboratories so data management
standards and clinical laboratories
most of us think at least people who are
functioning clinical laboratories if
you're not directly involved with the
maintenance and action of a clinical
laboratory information system you think
of it as a black box where you have
patient metadata tested instrument data
raw test data from instruments post
analysis results and test report test
result reporting all coming out and
surrounding the clinical laboratory
information management system
and there's some sort of workflow and
standard operating procedure that you've
established for using that information
system but often people don't understand
or don't are not aware about everything
that goes on inside the box
both in
how data is managed how quality is
assured
and how the data integrity is maintained
and
currently there aren't actually a lot of
regulations uh around
what actually goes inside that black box
so there's a lot of regulations
surrounding the information that goes in
it comes out
so in clea
for those of you who are familiar these
standards were started in 1988 which
really just discussed it really outlines
regulations and how um clinical
laboratories are
regulated regulates clinical laboratory
activities
and um and uh reporting and so some of
the data requirements that are
explicitly outlined in the clia
the clia regulations which i've linked
below if you're interested
is things like patient identification
specimen identification when the
data has come to the laboratory
what test was performed and hopefully
you have your tests on record so what
tests of on the record tests that you do
which test was performed and when the
test was done
the results from the data analysis and
information that any specimens that
didn't make it into your into your
laboratory because of quality issues so
that's there's there's a few others but
that's the main gist of what clio
requires for clinical reporting
and um there's also implicit quality and
management requirements in there for
example this confidential patient
information now these implicit quality
and data quality and management
requirements
are implicit that they don't actually
tell you what data is required how to
handle that data but they do require
certain actions on the laboratories part
to maintain that information for example
patient information should be kept
confidential so therefore your database
or data data store should be secure
also
you have to securely rate maintain your
uh your
test test results and your data uh for
about two years it explicitly says two
years so you have to have some way of
accurately storing it and and
maintaining that data
you also have to have data on the
testing systems that did the did the
analysis for example you have to have
information your reagents your
instruments your materials and supplies
that's implicit to the regulations and
also you have to have accurate result
reporting and your test reports have to
have a certain amount of data in them
and that reporting somehow has to come
out of your information management
system in a correct and accurate manner
to give the correct report to the
clinician
but there's no explicit guidance on the
quality of the data and that that
there's no
actual regulations that try to do
quality control on the data that's
within that clinical laboratory
information management system
uh by the way if you have any questions
that you can think of as i go through
this because this is the first time i've
given this talk and this is a talk i've
wanted to do for a while so i'm probably
not going to be clear on some things
feel free to start entering your
questions and answers if you're doing
this live
while i talk and at the end of the talk
i'll get to your questions and answers
and um and and interpret them and
tell the audience what you're asking and
stuff so
um so one of the crediting bodies is the
college of um
american pathologists and the cap
molecular pathology checklist is used
for accreditation
and they have this is outside they're
kind of a little bit more um
they have a specific molecular pathology
set of requirements for accreditation on
top of clia and recently they've added
standards section on bioinformatics
pipelines for next generation sequencing
which is really nice to see
uh there includes data analysis
standards for ngs for next generation
sequencing
pipeline documentation process
validation
quality control
data raw derived data storage i'll talk
more about this later on
essentially especially the version
tracking it's all very nice to see
because it's all stuff that wasn't
previously required for a lot of
laboratory data however especially
molecular data pardon me but um however
there's no other guidance really on data
management or processes for other
bioinformatics platform heavy platforms
such as microarrays or
high comp high complexity pcr
experiments like array pcr experiments
and that doesn't exist so they've done
taken this great step for next
generation sequencing but we're still
not completely there with the other
with workflows and data management for
for the other processes that are
commonly used in laboratories
um especially pgb laboratories so
there's also overall no guidance and cap
on their checklist for quality or best
management practices
in new york
in new york has a clinical laboratory
evaluation
process that
they
produce they produce several documents
it's actually quite rigorous and we've
worked with them because we're in new
jersey and new york state is right next
door so we actually work with uh the
department of health there and i they're
they're much more
complete in what they require from a
laboratory i found than some of the
other standards that are out there
and um
i don't know if they're the most uh the
most detailed of all the states but
they're pretty they're pretty detailed
so one of the things they do is they do
go through a laboratory information
management system requirements
um they are they some of them are um
they leave it up to the laboratory for
exactly what
uh
what implementation the information
management system takes whether or not
it's commercial or in-house but they do
have requirements such as test of
reported archive and maintain an
accurate reliable manner you have to
have proper maintenance of your limbs
for the manufacturer
so your limbs has to be updated
according to the standards of the
manufacturer your peripheral devices
like printers and such have to be
maintained your validation your limbs
has to be validated prior to use and you
should have it validated in a manner
that shows that your tests are
accurately reported and data is
accurately maintained um your data has
to be backed up and recovered and in
proper manners you have to have
provisions for the limbs failure and
some sort of backups process so in case
some something goes wrong with the lens
um
if the limbs fails you should be able to
go into the data and
access the data outside of the failure
of the limbs you have to have clinical
reporting requirements uh on amendments
amendment not only the original report
has to come out but there's certain
certain
requirements for amendments that have to
be added to their existing report so
they have that as part of their policy
they also have limited personnel access
according to permission so your limbs
have to have a have a hierarchy
hierarchical
permission system
under new york state and also you have
to have power surge protection ups power
backup which is perfectly reasonable to
expect
and also um they actually require
supervisor review of any manual entries
and adequate training for people
entering data into the limbs so this is
this is pretty good and um
we were we were happy to see a lot of
the feedback that we got when we were
going through this process
um
were coming from people who did some
very careful consideration of your
system so they don't rubber stamp things
in new york state they actually go
through your your
your uh process and they pay careful
attention to how things are done
um
however there even in new york state and
across the board in general there aren't
really explicit requirements for
personnel to certify to demonstrate
expertise in clinical data management
there's plenty of requirements for what
kind of laboratory supervisory
experience a laboratory supervisor has
to have
and other people with positions of
responsibility in the laboratory in the
clinical testing laboratory but there
aren't explicit
that i've been able to see
uh any kind of requirements for people
uh to have some sort of certification in
sql
or
laboratory information management
or hipaa or the people who actually
handle this data um including the lims
manufacturer there's no certification
for the people that do handle the data
there's also no certification process
for the information management tools
database systems there is no certified
limb system that could be used in a
clinical laboratory that's again
completely on the shoulders of the lab
and there's no oversight or regulation
for good data management practices in
the laboratory outside of of some of the
stipulations in the lymph system that
new york that uses there's um there's
there's uh
no uh
no stipulations for demonstrating data
integrity month to month or looking for
correctly normalized database tables or
so that the data that you put in last
year is still the data you have today
there's no checks on that
and there's no requirements to
demonstrate adequate data security
quality reliable and reproducibility and
in general i'm not i i haven't talked
about hipaa in this talk um i'm going to
assume that hipaa is in place that you
have correct firewalls and that your
data's
adequately adequately secure in your
environment
but outside of the security and access
security and backup kind of security the
kind of security i'm talking about is
security for
security against mistakes
so i guess it's an integrity security
there's not a lot of regulations
or checks in the inspections about to
make sure that the systems that you put
in place to handle this massive amount
of data are actually doing what they say
they do
so that black box is really the black
box
so in in quality driven data management
without external guidance we're actually
uh trying to we need to establish our
own vigorous internal standards and
protocols for automated data acquisition
um how we do that and how we make sure
that it's done
you know accurately um whether or not
automatic whether we we also have to um
have protocols for automated and
periodic tests and reviews for quality
assurance in our databases
we do quality control at the point of
data entry so there's tight quality
controls not only in the data that's
already in the database but in what
humans put in so the supervisor review
of our data is also
quality checks at the point of entry so
people can't put in a crazy date or put
in an unexpected value so those kinds of
things have to be
so the quality of the data going into
the database is monitored
and controlled also good data management
practices um
i'll go more into that a little bit but
some example could considerations were
are that um your data security you
should have pri your privacy proper
security and backup should be in place
um
your data integrity and design you
should have properly typed variables in
your database
you should have periodic checks for
variable ranges and outliers in your
data
you should have your data should be
proper your database should be properly
normalized in the case you're using a
relational database so that you don't
have
modifications that are not expected
also quality control you should have
easily accessible quality control
metrics for your data set and you should
have coupled you should also test the
performance of your lens or your data
sets to actually to your workflows to
actually see that they can they
accurately uh produce month to month the
same results that you expect them to
present to produce
also
what software implementation
you're using and whether or not the
systems
are using have demonstrated and have
demonstrated and been reviewed and
validated um on a periodic database and
not just the data quality control but
the systems that generate the data so
these are example considerations for
quality driven data management in
production
so
most labs have to go through this on
their own without guidance or inspection
again the black box is in place so
so for pgd and specifics um
we have three we have three different
methods we use for pgd
um
pgd is essentially
where pre-implantation genetic diagnosis
is a way of um
in the laboratory of determining um
whether or not an embryo
is a carrier for a particular disease or
whether or not it has the correct copy
number of chromosomes i talk about that
in a minute but for all this kind of
measures we we use three main
analysis methods right now at least here
at rma and one is pcr which we amplify
known sequences and we identify gene
disordered carrier statuses or
chromosome copy number analysis and
embryos
we use microarrays and other a lot of
other places do too especially array cgh
where you can utilize many thousands to
about a million different individual
markers
and these points will give you
information on deletions chromosomal
rearrangements or chromosomal copy
number status and that
currently snip arrays and array cgh are
used
and also this next gen sequencing or
second generation sequencing it's often
called and that can be used for
identifying gene disorder carrier status
or analyzing chromosomal copy number so
the methods in next-gen sequencing can
range from targeting specific regions to
look at particular carrier or affected
status
so looking for specific biomarkers or
sequence markers are also looking for
whole genome sequencing and
for different types of method like
chromosomal copy number
so data size examples for pgd platforms
if you're interested um pcr
expect you know 10 megabyte megabytes up
to 20 megabytes of data maybe if you're
storing per sample that's generous but
you know in terms of terabytes for two
years of data storage it's not very much
but as you move up the range if you go
to microarrays it's about between three
to five terabytes for two years of data
targeted ngs when you're looking at
small regions of the chromosome
for the next generation sequence next
generation sequencing we're looking for
specific markers and you're targeting
what sequence you're going to be
sequencing
um maybe eight terabytes a year if
you're doing 500 embryos a year but in
genomic ngs if if that's where it's
going it's going to be much larger and
you've probably heard about this data
sizes and next generation sequencing and
really depending on how deep and how
much sequencing you do per sample this
this may be even an underestimate having
a few gigabases uh sorry pardon me a few
gigabytes of data per embryo is probably
not
something that would be unusual if you
did whole genome sequencing on an embryo
and
and even with a conservative file size
of about a thousand um
for about uh one gigabyte of um
analyzed data size and about one
gigabyte of compressed data you're still
going to have to deal with about 24
terabytes over two years of storage if
you were doing all embryos this whole
genome sequencing which may or may not
happen but it's a it's a it's a
consideration for data size
so
um
in pgd information
in pgb laboratory settings
we have to assign unique ivs for patient
embryos these are the kinds of things
that we're considering to be important
for building a laboratory information
management system for pgd
we also
require automated tracking of samples
through a laboratory
we want detailed records on our reagents
and instruments we need to have data
activity and change tracking in the
database
we need to have end-to-end process flow
control um so that we know at all all
points where the samples are and uh how
the samples are moving through the
laboratory if there's any bottlenecks or
when the data is expected to be ready
especially in the cases of fresh fresh
embryo transfer
we need clinical reporting to required
standards that are laid out by the
accrediting bodies
and we also need to version all patient
reports so that all software and methods
that we're using are correctly
attributed to the version that they were
calculated under so we can go back and
redo the calculation you know in the
future days
knowing what software version we used
and of course we need persistent data
for two years even through database
updates
um
we also need to have quality metrics
available for reagents instruments data
process and analysis and we have to have
our workflows which i'll talk about in a
bit but our workflows um have to be
completely customized to our indication
and platform because workflows for pcr
are not exactly the same workflows for
next generation sequencing so
your laboratory information management
system should be flexible enough that
your workflows can be tailored and
adapted
so um let me go back a bit so developing
a custom limbs
when we when we considered um
actually let me i think i jumped forward
too far let me go through this one more
time here
let's see if i can get there we go
commercial limits for clinical pgd so
consider if you're thinking about having
a lymph system for pgb in your
laboratory or going to a commercial
system
or even if you use a commercial system
already some of the things that you have
to think about is how the system has
been validating different use cases and
if it's a good company they'll give you
lots of examples of how it's being used
in a good clinical laboratory and how
they keep up on validation that the data
is you know for data integrity and for
use they can give you lots of help and
information on how that's being done
um how can if it's a system that hasn't
been used for pgd but for other
laboratory environments you like the
system you have to ask yourself how
configurable is this system for pgd
what ongoing support does the date does
the software require sometimes it's not
as simple as just unrolling the software
and installing it there's sometimes an
ongoing support needed for both you know
correcting mistakes or extending the
software to do what you need to do so
you have to ask what ongoing support
does the software require and what kind
of costs
are required and how much work has to be
done to completely customize
their limb system to actually work for
pgd and for all laboratory uses in a pgd
laboratory
and cost for upgrading or additional
customization and growth
that's also also a concern
and also how easy does the software
customize for non-standard genetic tests
in pgd
and
ultimately does a limbs database a lot
allow transparency so even though the
lymph software is sitting on top of a
database are you able to access that
database cleanly from use even excusing
external tools to actually do due
diligence on the database or other types
of analysis on the database that you
don't need to go through the limb system
to do so doing third-party checks or
doing database integrity checks you need
to go through the limbs to do that maybe
sometimes the lens has things that built
in that you're able to do that
independently i mean it's built into the
lens system itself so this is the kind
of question you should consider
for us
we decided to develop a custom lens and
part of my job is to enable research
here at our main new jersey
by creating systems that make it very
easy for research to go smoothly as
possible
and i found that a lot of the commercial
software we looked at would also require
a bit of
programming basically or wrapper
wrapper writing there's no out of the
box perfect limb system that could come
out for pgd especially for a group like
ours where we do a lot of data
validation method validation and then
put it into production as a clinical
laboratory
so we developed a custom non-commercial
limbs that we paired with our validated
bioinformatics pipelines for microarray
pcr and phenol for next-gen sequencing
so the for the front end we built it in
cgi python we drive our web interfaces
and our we use the programming r and
python to actually uh drive the
analytics
on the back end we have an automatic set
of pipelines that do quality control and
analysis so the the model is is that the
pipelines automatically do all the data
acquisition from the machines
uh upload everything to the databases
calculate the results from the databases
from the database keep a record of all
the lot numbers um all the required
metadata like who did the analysis and
when all that data is stored in the
database
and at the front end of it when the
calculations are complete you can
visualize and
browse the data
according to any metric that you want to
look at we have several different
choices
you can also look at lab performance
from the raw data so we store the raw
data the derived data
and um
and
and all the metadata and it's all it all
talks to each other so it allows uh us
to have a lot of control
over quality in our data sets or at
least looking at quality or data sets so
we developed an iterative fashion almost
an agile software fashion um where we we
did a kind of an onion skin we had a
series of requirements uh for
functionality as a backlog and we
started adding them on to our to our
lynn system as we went over the period
of a year so we started with a core
functionality we had the back end
processing pipeline the results
presentation and sample tracking was the
most important stuff that we needed to
put in first and all the front end where
we actually did the sample tracking and
clinical diagnostic systems
um so the first part was more like an r
d part in the first stage the second
stage was the the finished product and
in the third stage we're adding in the
next generation sequencing pipelines for
uh for
copy number analysis of embryos and also
single gene disorder analysis so
building it up in a sequential
fashion made made a lot easier for us to
to develop on the fly
features that were required or only
discovered that were required later on
so
in our pgd data structure we have
essentially
three different arms of the pgd data
structure we have the patient
information that comes from the clinical
requests
we have our laboratory entity records
that are part of the laboratory the
actual laboratory function and then we
have our analysis records which are the
results of the of the statistical
analyses
so when we check in so for rma genetics
when a patient uh
requisition is checked in we have all
the patient information uh independent
of the actual samples that are run those
are usually sent to us ahead of time so
here's a patient she's going to have a
cycle
um it's usually focused around the
female
she's going to have a cycle we keep her
information her date of birth and other
other identifying materials and and when
her cycle will be when the samples do
come in we have the embryo records our
accession we
check them into our laboratory we also
at the same time have our instruments
reagents and lab metadata ready so that
when the embryos are checked into lab
and put on a plate or actual laboratory
entity such as a plate or a chip those
embryo records that were accessioned in
as as samples that came into the lab are
now linked
directly to the chip or the entity
that's doing the analysis so it would be
like a pcr chip an ngs
sequencing chip or a microarray analysis
chip so those entities have their own
ids and are tied directly back to the
embryo records
and in that case the let because we're
managing the laboratory entity records
as a separate database that entity rec
those entity records also connect to our
instruments our reagents and a lab
metadata and that entire
laboratory entity environment then can
also
connect out to the analysis results
which are done so the analysis results
are accessioned on the on the um are
able to be for foreign keys
um both between the embryo record that
was checked in that's connected to the
patient the laboratory entity records
and also the analysis records um and you
can actually access um
this and i'm leaving out a lot here too
but you can access any one of these
records from the other records so for
instance you can say what were all the
samples run on instrument x
and what were the performance on
instrument x uh on a certain date and
time what reagents were used what lot
reagent lots were used and how do the
plates and the embryo samples compare
between the reagent lots uh on average
um
you could look at lab metadata what kind
of uh what kind of you know what
particular
operator was doing what person was doing
the analysis that day or by date or by
operator
and you can see how the different plates
and chips performed under that one
particular person so we have a lot of
control to to see how the data is uh and
how the lab's performing
in our in our system so when we designed
the limbs we had uh we had different
considerations we had we had when you
design a limbs at all you have to
consider whether or not your data your
data structure and workflow should
really be designed together
uh it's hard to design your data system
first and then build a workflow on top
of that and vice versa it really should
be hand in hand
um we did data testing and validation
designed into the system so the system
has as much testing and uh data
validation built into it as
as as the
as the same amount as uh as the code
that's built in to manage the data so a
lot of our data is done on a testing
base a lot of our um
development was done on a on a test
space which i'll talk about in a bit on
a testing basis
um we maximize our automated processes
on the database so that the workflows
are completely automated
um
and we uh actually over designed for all
possible metadata needed to reproduce
results
um
we try to version control whatever
possible we plan for growth so there's a
lot of modularity in our data as you saw
in the pre in the slide with the with
the ovals um a lot of those databases
are modular and a lot of the workflows
around them are modular so that we can
change any one of those without having
to change the entire system and a lot of
good limbs uh are probably built like
that in the commercial world as well
um we also uh over provision the
database and system hardware so we try
to buy more than we need um because
we're always growing and we don't want
to have to suddenly say oh we need a new
system because we're it's getting too
tight
you want to have a lot of advanced uh
notice for that so
we over provision it now here's a slide
that was skipped and i know it's kind of
hard to see but this is an example
workflow for the for the data that we do
for it for a typical
pg pgd job so this is checking the
patient data
moving to
different job ids sample ids how the
samples handles we do video we do video
recording of different sample trend
samples are transferred we do video
recording of the sample to make sure
it's adequately done it's reviewed by a
by a laboratory supervisor
we go through and the data is analyzed
and there's electronic signatures from a
board-certified site of geneticist
this is all automated and there's very
little human interaction except for the
beginning of the pipeline and the end of
the pipeline
there's a couple of different check-in
states but usually they're automated and
it's a binary is it checked in or not
kind of setting so we tried to take out
the human um the human element as much
as possible without completely
removing it from controls
so there is there are stem steps where a
person could step in and change
something but on standard operating
procedure that's not done
um
so when we developed the limbs uh that
workflow was done on a test driven
development so we checked on quality
reproducibly and correct exception
handling uh in that when those errors
that were there were
that were found um
when there are errors that are found we
record them
and if there are problems with the um
with the software it doesn't just crash
it goes and does something appropriate
so if for some reason an incorrect value
slipped through or something came off
the machine that was unexpected which
sometimes happens
um the data should not simply just drop
and and the sample should not just
disappear from the horizon um what
should happen is it should be an
automatic email with the lim system
saying excuse me there's a problem with
this data it shouldn't just fail
um so there's a lot of exception
handling that was built in uh to our
limb system
the tests were defined up front before
the code was written so we said okay we
need to test to make sure that the
sample when it comes off the machine is
correctly entered into the database
there isn't a crash so in that case you
would define a test up front and when
you're when you're and then when you go
and test it on a on a sample your limb
system will always have that test in
place so you've built your code around
that test
and so there's other tests that i have
here we test we define tests for almost
every function in our laboratory
information management system um
and the code was written around the test
so they've successfully completed
and the tests actually remain as part of
the limbs so that we periodically run
those tests to see if everything's okay
in our test situation and if there's any
kinds of changes to the system or
changes to our instruments
if there's failures of our tests it
indicates a documentable problem and
this often our machines are often
updated by the manufacturer with new
software versions and more than once
we've caught with our limbs tests um
you know for instance
the loss of an instrument id being put
out um
or or
different uh challenges with the changes
and the changes in error reporting on
the on the sample output from there from
the instrument all those things actually
could change the way our our limb system
was operating and the tests the tests
that were run caught those
so
um
so quality checks and lens development i
talked about that
okay so automatic example automatic
workflow tests so one would be job
process
job accessioning every month uh we have
an automated system that creates a job
ticket it tests all exception handling
so all the things that could go wrong
when data's entered
we run that through a simple test and
then
and then at the end of the test we
should have a successful job
registration with the right data in it
and then it comes back and if you look
at the job if you look at the monthly
report it'll just say job process entry
okay because the okay means everything
is completed successfully if it doesn't
completely successfully on the report
it'll say not okay or actually we'll say
exception on it
um for analysis test processes we run uh
raw data from three embryos samples of
known status per month you can run them
through
um
you create data the process will create
database entries it'll send raw data
through the platform pipeline and it's
not fresh data off the machines it's
it's data of known characteristics we
kind of have benchmark data and the
final analysis results should replicate
against that benchmark previous
benchmark so you should get the exact
same result out no matter what changes
have been done on the limbs or in the
data or the reference anything like that
you should get expected results out down
to the decimal point and that's what
that's one way of running a test
another test that we can run
is laboratory test analysis performance
per month so summarize all the samples
run that month in a certain test
and you can flag any deviations beyond
some certain thresholds um
so some of that would be population uh
of sample population comparing you know
a previous month that you that you said
okay so for 2012 we're going to always
run february for example
check to see the february when we do our
our summary analysis february always
comes out to the correct value um so
you run february as a benchmark and
every month every month when you run
your test also run another test with
expected results so
you're not going to show that but you'll
say that you know that the test
parameters you ran should be expected
because the one that you knew about how
it should run came out to the same value
so that's another way of doing a test
analysis performance
um
so for copy number visualizations um i
want to go a little bit into
visualizations unfortunately i'm not
going to have a lot of time to go
completely into visualization like i
wanted to in my abstract
but there's certain things in um in our
limb system when it came out with
reports and for quality control measures
our copy number visualizations had to be
accurate to produce rapid and accurate
review of result uh views and reviews of
results chromosomal copy number analysis
um is essentially looking at uh
chromosomal counts per embryo so if
there's a trisomy 21 you should have
caught three copies of 21. if you have
a monosomy six you should have one copy
of six and it should be obvious in your
visualization that that's what you have
so that when your cytogeneticist was
looking through results
he or she not only has the table in
front of them but also a visualization
that's accurately reflecting what's in
the table
so it should also include pertinent
information like the patient information
directly on the chart and that should be
part of the limbs you shouldn't just
have a chart on top but you know on to
one side with the data that the data
should be
put on the chart to show that when the
data analysis was run it was run on that
particular patient that particular
sample so that should come with forward
with the chart
um
it should convey complex information and
easy to read layout it should include
validated measures of variation it
should include decision thresholds on
the chart also it should provide alerts
on the chart but data is outside an
acceptable range uh we use asterisks and
bolding but you could use whatever you
want
as long as it lets the reviewer know
that this data is somehow outside of
nominal range
we also provide multiple detailed view
types for the same data
and that often helps because sometimes
one view of data isn't always the best
isn't always the best view of the data
so here's an example of
one very one analysis um sorry what uh
one copy number testing visualization we
use
and here's a cell site uh
a cell line sample of plus 16 plus 21.
this chart is just an r and we um
the bars indicate uh the chromosomes
and you can see that uh 16 and 21 are
elevated above the the blue bars which
are empirically derived cutoffs for for
those chromosomes
and their copy number three
and you can see x and y there are
monosomies meaning this is a male uh
it's a sex male sample and those were
our monosomies and the little numbers
above each one is the z score of
deviation from from the normal reference
distribution of
copy number two
chromosomes so it helps in decision
making for the cytogeneticists
so this particular view is supported by
another view we've done with heat maps
and here i have an example of um that
was recently published by our group
where we were able to use the heat maps
to identify incidental i did incidental
balance translocation carrier patients
um so the heat maps are normally used as
another view of
our assays and how the at least in pcr
the pcr that we're using our assay
responses to copy number
and in this case uh if you have a
trisomy it tends to be very bright white
and if it's a monosomy it tends to go
down to red
so um and and think of hot iron you know
going from deep glowing red to very
bright glowing white so that heat map
rep so most of the orange colors mean
copy number two it's in the median range
in this example we have chromosome 10
and 13 have
a translocation
where
part of 13 is in these cases unbalanced
translocations of parts of 13 are lost
and parts of 10 are gained
so these um
these unbalanced translocations also you
would not be able to catch that in the
previous plot it would have just shown
that some of the data
the data's variation was out of range
but by using this plot on on this on the
on the plate surface you can actually
see the
the locations of the um
of the translocations and that was
something that that we actually have
seen more more this more than once but
this is one example that we recently
published
okay so
that's the visualization part um i have
more visualizations unfortunately i
can't show them yet because some of the
methods we're working on is still not
published
and if you if you look me up next year
i'll have some really interesting visual
visualizations for copy number next gen
sequencing
but i can't show you that right now
because of the intellectual property
issue and pre-publication issues so
unfortunately i can't do much more than
that
um
for pre-implantation genetic diagnosis
by next generation sequencing i'm going
to talk a little bit a little bit about
this i wish i could do more but again
we're working on this still and
we're in the process of finishing up our
protocol so i can't talk about it yet
but you'll probably see this in print
sometime soon
but i will talk about the process
um our sequencing pipeline most
sequencing pipelines go along this
process where you have your data from
your sequencer you do sequence
re-trimming and filtering sort of a
pre-alignment
conditioning of your data you do an
alignment to your reference you do
alignment refinement if you want that
alignment to even be better aligned
there are software that will do that
you do some sort of variant calling if
you're looking for particular gene
variants and you can do various
statistical analysis if you're doing
copy number the calling part doesn't
necessarily have to happen other
statistical analyses will happen at that
point
which will yield a copy number from your
data
now in cap we talked about earlier in
the presentation how cap has now got a
new bioinformatics pipeline for next
generation sequence requirements they
also have a section in there for
maternal plasma next generation
sequencing for fetal genetic tests where
you can actually short sequence shorter
dna reads that you actually obtain from
maternal blood can be used to identify
are embry are assumed to be fetal and
embryonic dna that enters in the
maternal blood and interestingly enough
you can use that to do some
genetic diagnosis
on the on the on the
embryo and
you can actually do copy number analysis
as well and sex sex the embryo so
all this can be done in maternal plasma
and even though there's not a pgd
specific set of requirements in cap
those interested in maybe what what
could eventually come along as as
requirements for pgd at least through
cap you might be able to see some of
that in the next gen sequencing
for fetal genetic tests for the
bioinformatics pipelines for ngs
requirements uh this happened in july
and cat last july in 2012 and cap has
actually had a working group i believe
together that got together and
determined what kind of information
would be necessary to to support
clinical use of next generation
sequencing
um so
including in that is the documentation
uh revalidation of the data analysis
process
um quality uh management programs any
kind of update policies what happens
when software is updated um what kind of
storage policies you have for the three
main files that people often use for
next generation sequencing including
fastq which is your raw read data your
bams which are your alignment binary
alignment files
and your vcf which you're calling
variant calling format files so all
those files are usually they're they're
quite large vms are slightly smaller
than fast queues and bcf's are slightly
smaller than bams but they're all
they're all
uh
pardon me they're all they're all kind
they're all there
i mean they're all very um
they're all very large
so we should have versioning traceable
for each patient report
um
and we should have storage policies
pardon me i'm gonna i'm having problems
with my phone
i'm hanging it up
um
we also need exception logging with
pipeline processes vary from the uh
standard operating procedures and our
data transfer confidentially
data transfer confidentiality policy has
to be in place
um all these are requirements in cap i
have the link there at the bottom i
really if you want to do ngs i suggest
you read this before you embark on it
because if you plan on doing
accreditation through cap because it's
actually pretty intelligent and um i've
read through it and i think it's a the
right way to go
at least with the beginning of
accreditation of next-gen sequencing
um so for the last few minutes i want to
talk about
applications of
pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis and next-gen
sequencing and human genetics but before
i go much more into that
um i want to talk about what's already
been done so there's there's been
several markers that people have worked
on
um
for clinical uh through clinical labs
and uh rapid discovery and next-gen
sequencing but there aren't any clinical
trials right now that have been
validating the use of ngs for pgd on on
a clinical on a on a laboratory basis
for single gene or copy number analysis
meaning that there's there's no clinical
trial that's helping to set up a
standard
so
methods actually have been used though
to identify deleterious changes in a
genome so there's been in one paper is
an example where um
automatic neuropathy where sensory
autonomic neuropathy caused by mutation
dystonian where i believe an exon of
dystonia was missing in affected
and affected families and was recently
published in 2012 and part of that was
done through lots of heterozygosity
analysis coupled with whole exome
sequencing
and of course this had to be validated
and it was published but it things like
uh this method of rapid discovery
through next-gen sequencing and then
validation which is an important part i
don't mention the slide but i have to
point out that that there are a lot of
variations that could be responsible you
have to valid obviously the
variance have to be validated as
positive but once that's done
the discoveries can allow for selection
against effective carrier status with
pgd testing on embryos and this can go
and there's a lot of different ways that
this can be applied
um
uh
specifically for for for more complex
disorders like autism or
or adult onset diseases we may
eventually get to the point where we'll
have the opportunity
to select embryos
who are less likely to get certain
diseases
so in the workflow design considerations
for next-gen sequencing if you're
thinking about it it has a unique set of
requirements for analysis
if you remember the earlier slide i
showed with the bunch of work the
workflow for ngs each step could be a
different piece of software that is
often rapidly versioned
so ngs workflows have not quite reached
commercial maturity since most of the
software is is publicly available
it's
because they're academically designed so
the rate of development and change in
the software is pretty high
um some of it some of it's pretty pretty
established but there's always room for
improvement and it's still a developing
pla developing method so
um especially as the as the data density
gets bigger and bigger there's going to
be more and more software comes out to
manage the data so
um that's a that's a design
consideration in your whatever
platform you use to do ngs sequencing
now pgd applications really
require tailored specific parameters to
optimize the results of next-gen
sequencing it's not as simple as just
throwing it against a reference and
seeing you get out there has to be some
statistic there has to be some
statistical analysis that's not going to
necessarily come directly out of
academic commercial software so you're
going to need some statistical uh
statistical analysis support from a good
statistician with experience especially
if you're doing methods development
um and because there's also no
one-size-fits-all analysis solutions for
our exam so some examples that i have
here are that from mitochondrial
heteroplasmy analysis if you're
interested in doing that
it hasn't been
for research purposes you have a small
reference about sixteen thousand base
pairs
and to look for heteroplasma you have to
somewhat relax parameters and your
data's a small the medium data size so
you don't have really large data but
your parameters your alignment software
are going to be different than if you
did targeted gene disorders where you
want to have
pretty strict alignment requirements um
you don't want to line junk to your
to your reference but you also um have a
different requirement for chromosomal
copy number analysis and they'll have
yet another requirement for variant
discovery so all those requirements of
different settings in your software that
if you use these as a laboratory
as a laboratory test you're going to
have to record they're all going to be
different parameters all recorded
separately and differently for each
method that you use
so it's almost like you have a different
assay or a different platform even
though you're using the same platform at
ngs the software and the requirements in
that entire pipeline can be completely
different between two applications
so that's so it's no one size fits all
and please keep that in mind if you're
designing your workflows
um so choices for ngspg workflows you
know your choices are if you want to set
up a workflow is you can only do simple
you could stay with the simple analyses
like single gene disorder type of
analyses we have a small reference and a
targeted amplification
and in a commercial often you could
probably find a commercial vendor that
will support those results to support
that pipeline or
you could probably hire a bioinformatics
or data analysis expert professional to
research and design workflows that are a
little bit more complex for you if
you're doing research and development
coupled with clinical testing
or you could hire consultants there are
plenty of good teams out there that that
are bioinformatics teams that can help
you put in place a pipeline i've worked
in organizations that have done that
before where the pipeline would be more
of a work a day thing they can come and
install a pipeline validate it for you
it costs money but but they're available
often for updates and upgrades so if you
have a good relationship with that kind
of person or that kind of group it can
it can it can be useful for your
organization and you're not often tied
down to one particular product and they
have a lot of experience so you leverage
that too
or you can wait for commercial software
out of the box developers to catch up
with ngs development hope they include
your method of interest whatever you're
interested in but ultimately in all
cases the rate of development for ngs is
very high so any established solution
you put into place may change um both in
the platform that it's being used or
there might be upgrades and and
data density a greater bigger chips
um more accurate results uh error rates
that are different from platform to
platform so so anything that you put in
now may be different a year from now so
that's another thing you should consider
so if you do consider building this or
partnering with someone or using
commercial software try to try to figure
out if it's going to be
able to be used a year from now or if
you project that it could be used a year
from now
and a little bit in the last five
minutes i have here i'm going to talk a
little about human genetics and future
pre-implantation genetic genomics
directions
uh really we're all about assessing
reproductive potential here at rma and
we're interested in um
and thinking about uh where pg pgd might
go even if it's even if our um
considerations are way out there like
where where might it go in the future
so um
to understand
where we are in terms of human genetics
there's been two main efforts to catalog
genetic similarities and differences in
human beings because in order to
understand uh where genetic diagnosis is
going to go we should understand the
background of what we're operating in so
and understand the typical genomic
landscape and genetic landscape of the
average individual to quantify typical
variations is the hapmap project which
began back in 2002 and surveyed about a
million sniffs per individual these are
single nucleotide polymorphs
polymorphisms that help both uh say
something about genetic diversity and
also about
inherited conditions that individuals
may have most of these hapmap
individuals did not have any inherited
conditions associated with them so it's
more of a population analysis level that
we're looking at here so they took
hundreds of individuals from about eight
populations at known variant locations
and tried to see what kind of genetic
background were in each
individual population which i'll talk
about in a bit
there's also recently the thousand
genomes project where it published an
integrated map of genetic variation for
about a thousand different human genomes
and they sequence billions of genomic
locations per subject over 14
populations and that is available now
publicly if you're interested in looking
at it
um
uh
both the picture of some of the hat map
project individuals and additional
individuals so you can compare the two
if you're interested
um
they did discover or it seems to be
dropping off here but what they
discovered was about 38 million
different single nine single nucleotide
polymorphism loci in human and human
genome about 1.4 million insertions of
deletions that were less than 50 bases
wide
and about 14 000 large deletions and
functional genomes so there's a lot of
diversity just in the small amount of
population that they did
um
roughly about a thousand people which is
it's definitely not the entire diversity
in the human genome it's just a fraction
of it but even in this fraction we found
an awful lot of diversity
so to give you an example of what i mean
by diversity here's a slide with an
image from a paper at the top if you
want to go look it up it's a great read
it's the thousand genomes project
publication that was uh published in
nature back in 2012
and this is just a thousand kb
range across two genes
and light blue is agreement with the
reference sequence of the human
reference human genome reference
sequence like hg19 um
so in light blue are the agreement
locations in the background there and
white were single nucleotide
polymorphism locations that were known
so these people have variations and that
locations are known
on the on the right hand side going
across the screen
is each individual the very
each individual is very small it's only
a very thin line i think some of the
little black lines you see there are
probably representative a single
individual
uh we have four populations represented
here we have the american indian or
american
group at the top then the african group
below them
eastern asian
so that would be japanese chinese and in
beijing and i think chinese in america
and then european tsi would be toskins
or tuscany ceu or uh groups in utah uh
iberian i think finnish and great
britain
in african we have uh
reuben
and uh african-americans in the
southwest and uh
i forget the lwk
uh and then we have mexicans and other
groups from america
so the genetic diversity you can see
first of all in african americans you
have an awful lot of genetic diversity
and the reason you can see that is the
little blue crosses which look like
little tiny blue specks on there are
rare variants with less than five
percent um
five percent uh in the population
uh in the bottom of the entire graph you
see little black tick marks those are
novel variants that have not been seen
before
in little green arrows below there you
can see where there's indels that are
found in each individual
and
the little blue tick marks are the rare
variants that say something about uh
some of the rarer variations that happen
in the individual so if you're trying to
look for disease disease status or doing
genomic association studies uh these
representative little blue marks are
pretty much um
the kind of if any of these are
representative of a disease you're going
to have a
you're going to need to sample a lot of
individuals to get the power to see
their effect
um
but if you want more details on this and
others you should go read the paper
because it's it's a really good insight
into what kind of diversity uh we're up
against in doing genetic analysis in the
human genome
so the functional consequences of
variation apparently about 1.5 percent
of the total genome codes for the
genomes 2 20 000 proteins and then we
know for about uh we know about 75 of
those proteins we need we know some
information some information on the
biological function whether it's in a
specific tissue or overall how they
function and that's actually kind of
generous it's 75 percent is is
you know
even even if we know that it's expressed
in a certain tissue under certain
conditions and we kind of know a little
bit about that biological function we
can say it's a kinase uh then then we
know something about it but there's
still a lot of genes we know very little
about how they function in every tissue
dr mar presented yesterday about some of
that um if you want to go look up our
presentation about the differences in
expression of some of these genes and
how functionally they may differ in
between different tissues so there's a
lot of variation again that we don't
understand so we don't know very much
about every possible function the
proteins and interactions and some
variations of protein coding regions are
deleterious which we we find that there
should be a loss or decrease of the
protein's function or that's predicted
and if we disrupt the sequence that
helps regulate when and where these gene
products are actively produced
i mean some of these variations may
actually disrupt
wearing when those are produced by
disrupting the translational
machinery um
and also there's predicted deleterious
deleterious variations that may have
some significance some or no observable
consequence to health
so that's about the the 1.5 percent of
the genome that we that we see
where there's exons and we may have
variations
um
that might be uh cause disease but the
other 98 of the genome we don't really
have an idea of how the function but the
functional consequence of variation
across the rest of the genome that is
not exons that produce proteins we don't
really know how that affects the
function of the genome to tackle some of
this the encode project which is
published back in 2012 was actually
looking at functional dna limits and
systematically mapped regions associated
with functional consequences of gene
production and control
so they actually were able to function
to assign some sort of biochemical
function a role to about 80 percent of
the human genome or at least the 80
percent they looked at but it doesn't
necessarily include any kind of
physiological function like how would
affect a patient
um or implication of variations or
functions to those to the overall health
of the individual only kind of a
functional
expected function on a molecular
paradigm
so an encode they used one particular
genome and they were able to show that
that
a lot of these variants actually may
cause a functional effect and
a lot of these are outside of protein
coding genes so when we're doing
analysis on exomes to look for diseases
in our in our individuals there may be
things outside the exomes that are
causing a particular disease or a
phenotype that we're interested in
trying to test for so in that case whole
genome sequencing may become important
targeted sequencing of exons may be
limiting us in some cases um to
functional variants that are only inside
exons and not outside
i'm going to skip this slide but you can
you can catch up with this at the at the
paper earlier cited but essentially the
take home on this is that uh
people
you know humans may each
contain each of us may carry a few
hundred delete
potentially deleterious mutations that
we've either um
de novo or inherited from our parents
um
and the implications of these rare
variant findings are that you know the
rapid growth of human populations
um have allowed many of these rare low
frequency variants to spread between
countries and between regions
and so
because humans carry greater than
expected number of rare variations in
the population these rare variants um
uh are actually going to be isolated to
small groups or individuals so the power
to to detect these in particular disease
states if you're trying to use
populations of people with certain
diseases and do g wash studies as we've
already learned in the past several
years it's difficult to do because you
may not have enough power
um
so
so why attempt ngspgd
uh well
one reason to attempt it is that there's
a sheer num the sheer number of human
variant loci that i just briefly
discussed
coupled with the elusive genetic origins
of several disorders suggests that there
may be variations causing these
disorders
in subtypes that thought to be single
origin so we may want to do whole genome
sequencing and do some r d coupled with
our clinical testing because autism for
example may be maybe there's evidence
that it may be a struck a spectrum of
disorders caused by different variations
because we haven't been able to nail
down any one particular variation that
causes autism
um you could also uh couple single gene
disorder screening with chromosome copy
number analysis based on whole genome
sequencing of embryo genomes sorry i'm
reading from the slide but that's
essentially uh we could that's how we
could use from it that's how we could
use it in our pg labs pgd labs in the
future that are not engaged in genetics
research
um because of the challenge with whole
genome sequencing and trying to identify
causal variants
i personally don't think that pgv labs
are going to be engaged in genetics
research on the level of whole genome
sequencing unless they're doing genetics
research but if they're not i don't
think that they're going to be having a
great call for whole genome sequencing
in the near future
just because of the the sheer
statistical analysis and power that have
been that will be needed to identify
causal variants and of course the
validation steps so
um next generation sequencing uh going
forward for most uh laboratories is
probably going to be targeted and that's
my take on it
and of course target and specific whole
genome sequencing analysis for copy
number
um
so
i just want to
go through the the people i want to
thank mostly
we're a team effort here at rma we have
everyone we have research and nursing
support to andrology support here uh
there are whole teams of people involved
in in making our clinical program uh
successful
including our doctors who dedicate a lot
of their free time to our clinical uh
trials
we have clinical embryology and we have
some great um embryologists at work and
of course uh the market biology lab here
under dr nathan trev who runs the
molecular biology side um we have a
great team of people doing our analyses
and um i have working for me dr bothell
deaf coda that helps me
with the limb system and the research
and analysis system
and that's pretty much my talk
um
you can uh for continuing education
credits based on the slides that were
here you can go to bioconferencelive
dot cme dash slash cme dash ce
and you can also go over my slides again
in the future and um and take your cme
see me credits that way so i'm going to
look at the q a and see if there's any
questions i don't see any
so if anyone has any questions
we have a couple minutes
we start a little late
so does anyone have any questions
doesn't look like we do
well thanks for sticking through a
little bit of a dry conversation but um
hopefully next year if i give this talk
again i'll have a lot more information
to show on next-gen sequencing and how
we're using it for pgd
and thank you very much